HAVE A GOOD WEEKEND, EVERYBODY.
WE WILL SEE YOU BACK ON MONDAY.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THE ARRIVAL OF THE CHINESE
CORONAVIRUS HAS PUT TENS OF
MILLIONS OUT OF WORK, REALLY
HURT THE ECONOMY BADLY.
BUT THE CRISIS IS ALSO FORCED TO
THE CENTER SERIOUS CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT ISSUES THAT MATTER TO THE
FUTURE OF THE COUNTRY.
ISSUES LIKE THE DANGEROUS RISE
OF CHINESE GLOBAL DOMINANCE, THE
POOREST IN US OUR DOMESTIC
BORDERS, THIS COUNTRIES
CRUMBLING INFRASTRUCTURE,
GOVERNMENT MEANT INCOMPETENCE.
YOU MAY HAVE ASKED YOURSELF WHY
WEREN’T WE TALKING ABOUT THESE
BEFORE?
THAT’S A GOOD QUESTION, WE
DIDN’T HAVE TIME.
IF THERE WAS NO TIME TO CONSIDER
THE HEALTH OF AMERICA BECAUSE WE
WERE BUSY TALKING ABOUT RUSSIA.
IN WASHINGTON, RUSSIA IS ALL WE
TALKED ABOUT FOR THREE YEARS.
ALL NORMAL BUSINESS IN THE
CAPITAL CITY IT CAME TO A HALT
AS WE EMBARKED ON A BIZARRE
SCAVENGER HUNT IN SEARCH OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN’S SPIES.
EVEN AT THE TIME, THE WHOLE
THING SEEMED ABSURD.
IF WE IT WAS WORSE THAN ABSURD.
THIS WASN’T WHAT WE THOUGHT IT
WAS, IT WAS INSTEAD AN ELABORATE
AND INTENTIONAL HOAX STAGED BY
THE MOST UNSCRUPULOUS AND
POWERMAD POLITICAL OPERATIVES
THE COUNTRY HAS EVER SEEN.
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT?
THEY HAVE ADMITTED IT.
YESTERDAY, THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE CHAIRED
BY CONGRESSMAN ADAM SCHIFF OF
CALIFORNIA FINALLY RELEASED 57
TRANSCRIPTS OF TESTIMONY
DELIVERED TO THE COMMITTEE
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS, ALL OF IT
DURING THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
WHAT DO THOSE TRANSCRIPT TO
REVEAL?
WE ARE NOT GOING TO ASK YOU TO
TRUST US ON THIS ONE, INSTEAD WE
WILL QUOTE DIRECTLY FROM THE
TRANSCRIPT.
JIM KLAPPER SAID THIS "I NEVER
SAW ANY DIRECT EMPIRICAL
EVIDENCE OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
OR SOMEONE IN IT PLOTTING OR
CONSPIRING WITH THE RUSSIANS TO
MEDDLE WITH THE ELECTION."
COMPARE THAT TO HIS TWITTER
FEED.
SAMANTHA POWER MEANWHILE WAS
ASKED BY THE COMMITTEE IF SHE
HAD ANY EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION
WITH THE RUSSIANS, SHE REPLIED
"I AM NOT IN POSSESSION OF
ANYTHING.
I AM NOT IN POSSESSION AND DID
NOT GET INFORMATION FROM THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY."
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR SUSAN
RICE SAID I DON’T RECALL
INTELLIGENCE I WOULD CONSIDER
EVIDENCE.
AMAZING.
HERE IS FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL
LORETTA LYNCH.
IF SHE SAW EVIDENCE OF RUSSIAN
COLLUSION, SHE REPLIED THIS WAY
"I DO NOT RECALL THAT BEING
BRIEFED TO ME."
NOTICE THE WORD CHOICE, HERE I
DO NOT RECALL.
FOR THREE YEARS, OUR ENTIRE
POLITICAL SYSTEM REVOLVED AROUND
THE HUNT FOR RUSSIAN SPIES.
WE WERE TOLD AGAIN AND AGAIN IN
ORDER TO JUSTIFY IT THAT
COLLUSION WAS THE GREATEST CRIME
EVER COMMITTED IN AMERICAN
HISTORY, A CRIME AGAINST THE
STATE.
IT UNDERMINED OUR DEMOCRACY.
IF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES CLAIMS SHE "DOES
NOT RECALL" THAT ANY OF IT WAS
TRUE, SHE WOULD HAVE BEEN
CHARGED WITH PERJURY ON THE
SPOT.
WE WOULD BE WATCHING HER
SENTENCING RIGHT NOW.
AND OF COURSE, SHE PROBABLY
THOUGHT THE TRANSCRIPT OF THOSE
REMARKS WOULD NEVER BE MADE
PUBLIC.
THAT WAS CLEARLY THE ASSUMPTION.
THE FORMER DEFENSE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL 40 OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
NEWS OUTLETS SCRAMBLED FOR
PUPPETS WITH LEGITIMATE SOUNDING
RESUMES TO PUSH THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION NARRATIVE.
YOUNG PEOPLE WOULD SAY ANYTHING.
HERE SHE WAS IN MARCH OF 2017.
>> I WAS URGING MY FORMER
COLLEAGUES, IT WAS MORE AT
TELLING THE PEOPLE TO GET AS
MUCH INTELLIGENCE AS YOU CAN,
BEFORE PRESIDENT OBAMA LEAVES
THE ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE I HAD
A FEAR THAT THAT INFORMATION
WOULD DISAPPEAR WITH THE SENIOR
PEOPLE WHO LEFT.
IT WOULD BE HIDDEN AWAY, AND
BUREAUCRACY THAT THE TRUMP FOLKS
IF THEY FOUND OUT HOW WE KNEW
WHAT WE KNEW ABOUT THE TRUMP
STAFF DEALING WITH RUSSIANS,
THAT THEY WOULD TRY TO
COMPROMISE THOSE SOURCES MEANING
WE WOULD NO LONGER HAVE ACCESS
TO THAT INTELLIGENCE.
SO I BECAME VERY WORRIED,
BECAUSE NOT ENOUGH IS COMING OUT
INTO THE OPEN AND I KNEW THAT
THERE WAS MORE PEOPLE.
THAT’S WHAT YOU HAVE LEAKING.
WE HAVE VERY GOOD INTELLIGENCE
ON RUSSIA.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE VERY GOOD
INTELLIGENCE ON RUSSIA.
SAID DR. EVELYN FARKAS.
WE KNEW WHAT WE KNEW, BUT SHE
DIDN’T KNOW ANYTHING.
FARKAS WAS LYING, AS PURELY AS A
LIAR CAN LIE.
ONCE UNDER OATH, BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS, FARKAS ADMITTED THAT "I
DIDN’T KNOW ANYTHING."
IT WAS ALL LIES, LITERALLY ALL
OF IT.
EVEN THE COURT CLAIMS ABOUT
HACKING THAT FORMED THE BASIS OF
THE ENTIRE STORY AND THE
INVESTIGATION THAT FOLLOWED.
IN 2016, DURING THE CAMPAIGN,
SOMEONE STOLE INFORMATION FROM
THE DNC EMAIL SERVER THAT
EMBARRASSED HILLARY CLINTON.
DEMOCRATS QUICKLY BLAMED THAT ON
RUSSIA AND DONALD TRUMP.
IN FACT, THERE WAS NEVER REAL
EVIDENCE THAT THAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED.
THE DNC, YOU WILL REMEMBER,
NEVER ALLOWED FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS TO INSPECT THEIR
EMAIL SERVERS.
THAT’S ON BEHAVIOR FOR PEOPLE
WHO CLAIM TO BE THE VICTIMS.
INSTEAD, THE SERVERS WERE
INSPECTED BY A THIRD PARTY
COMPANY CALLED CROWD TO STRIKE,
ALL OF THIS COMING BACK TO YOU?
ADAM SCHIFF’S COMMITTEE
INTERVIEWED THE CEO OF CROWD
STRIKE JOHN HENRY.
HE QUESTIONED HIM DIRECTLY, IF
HENRY KNEW WHEN THE RUSSIANS HAD
STOLEN DATA.
HIS REPLY WHICH WE ARE SEEING
FOR THE FIRST TIME WAS THIS.
"AS IT RELATES TO THE DNC, WE
HAVE INDICATORS THAT DATA WAS
INFILTRATED.
WE DO NOT HAVE CONCRETE
EVIDENCE."
LATER, HENRY ADMITTED HE HAD
ONLY "CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE
DOES QUOTE THAT THE RUSSIANS
WERE INVOLVED AT ALL.
ADAM SCHIFF HEARD THOSE WORDS
DIRECTLY, HE HEARD IT FROM THE
ONE PERSON WHO WOULD KNOW FOR
CERTAIN.
ADAM SCHIFF KNEW THERE WAS
NOTHING SUBSTANTIAL AT THE CORE
OF THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION STORY,
AT THE VERY CENTER IT WAS
HOLLOW, A SHAM.
HE NEVER EVEN SUGGESTED THIS IN
PUBLIC, AND SAID HE THE
OPPOSITE.
HE SPENT YEARS ON TELEVISION
TELLING YOU IT WAS TOTALLY REAL,
SHUT UP.
>> THERE IS CLEAR EVIDENCE ON
THE ISSUE OF COLLUSION, AMPLE
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION IN PLAIN
SIGHT.
>> HAVE DEMOCRATS FOUND ANY
EVIDENCE?
>> YES WE HAVE.
YOU CAN SEE EVIDENCE IN PLAIN
SIGHT ON THE ISSUE OF COLLUSION,
PRETTY COMPELLING EVIDENCE.
THERE IS SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
OF PEOPLE IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
WITH THE RUSSIANS.
>> THERE IS SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION BETWEEN THE
CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA.
>> Tucker: IN CASE YOU WEREN’T
COUNTING DURING THAT MONTAGE,
ADAM SCHIFF SAID EVIDENCE NINE
TIMES.
AND EVERYTHING WILL TIME, HE WAS
LYING.
IT WAS FAIRLY OBVIOUS AT THE
TIME IF YOU WERE FOLLOWING
CLOSELY, HE NEVER PRODUCED ANY
OF THE SO-CALLED "EVIDENCE" THAT
THE DNC SERVER WERE HACKED BY
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
SEVERAL TIMES ON THE SHOW, WE
RAISED THE QUESTION DO WE REALLY
KNOW THIS?
A GROUP OF RETIRED INTELLIGENCE
OFFICERS SAID ACTUALLY, THAT
DIDN’T HAPPEN AND HERE’S HOW WE
KNOW.
WE CAME UNDER ENORMOUS PRESSURE
TO BE QUIET GOOD YOU’RE CRAZY,
KNOW THAT FOR A FACT BUT WE
DIDN’T KNOW IT.
WHEN HE CAME ON THE SHOW, WE ASK
HIM HOW DO YOU KNOW THIS?
HE NEVER ANSWERED OUR QUESTION,
HE ACCUSED US OF TREASON.
>> ABSOLUTELY, THE GOVERNMENT OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN WAS BEHIND THE
ATTACKS.
NOT ONLY IN THE UNITED STATES,
BUT ALSO IN EUROPE.
>> Tucker: I KNOW THEY DID.
>> YOU ARE CARRYING WATER FOR
THE KREMLIN.
>> Tucker: I’M NOT CARRYING
WATER FOR THE KREMLIN!
YOU CAN’T SAY THEY HACKED --
>> YOU WILL HAVE TO MOVE OUR
SHOW TO YOUR RUSSIAN TELEVISION.
>> Tucker: A NORMAL PERSON
WOULD NOT BEHAVE THAT WAY,
CONSCIENCE WOULD PREVENT IT.
ADAM SCHIFF IS A SOCIOPATH.
HE WILL DO OR SAY ANYTHING TO
ACHIEVE POWER, HE IS UNFIT TO
HOLD OFFICE, HE SHOULD RESIGN.
AND NOT JUST ADAM SCHIFF, THE
ENTIRE APPARATUS OF OFFICIAL
WASHINGTON HAS BEEN EXPOSED BY
THESE TRANSCRIPTS, AS WELL AS BY
THE DOCUMENTS RELEASED IN THE
MICHAEL FLYNN CASE WE WENT OVER
LAST NIGHT.
IN NOVEMBER OF 2019, GOVERNMENT
ATTORNEY DEFENDED THE FBI’S
DECISION TO INTERROGATE FLYNN AT
THE WHITE HOUSE WITH NO LAWYER.
"THE FBI WAS ENGAGED IN A
LEGITIMATE AND SIGNIFICANT
INVESTIGATION INTO WHETHER
INDIVIDUALS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CAMPAIGN OF THEN CANDIDATE
DONALD TRUMP WERE COORDINATING
WITH THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT."
IN THAT SAME FILING, HE WROTE
THAT FLYNN’S PHONE CALL WITH THE
RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR WAS ESSENTIAL
IMPORTANCE.
IT WAS IMPERATIVE THAT THE FBI
DETERMINE WHETHER AND WHY SUCH
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE RUSSIAN
AMBASSADOR HAD OCCURRED.
BOTH OF THOSE STATEMENTS WE NOW
KNOW CONCLUSIVELY OUR LIVES.
THE FBI HAD ALREADY KNOWN THAT
THERE WAS NO DEROGATORY
INFORMATION TYING MICHAEL FLYNN
TO THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
NOR DID THEY NEED TO KNOW
WHETHER FLYNN HAD SPOKEN WITH
AMBASSADOR.
THEY KNEW FOR A FACT HE HAD,
BECAUSE THEY WERE LISTENING AT
THE TIME.
THEY HAD A WORD FOR WORD
TRANSCRIPT OF THE CALL.
IN OTHER WORDS, BAND HE WAS LYIN
HIS FILING.
THIS IS NOT ONLY OF IMPORTANCE
TO DONALD TRUMP AND PEOPLE WHO
WORK FOR HIM OR PEOPLE WHO VOTED
FOR HIM, THIS IS IMPORTANT TO
EVERY AMERICAN BECAUSE THINGS
FALL APART QUICKLY WHEN
HIGH-LEVEL OFFICIALS DO THINGS
LIKE THIS FOR POLITICAL REASONS.
LOOK AROUND.
DO YOU KNOW ANYBODY WHO TRUSTS
THE GOVERNMENT ANYMORE?
THERE IS A REASON FOR THAT.
AND IT’S NOT GOOD.
IT’S THINGS LIKE THIS.
AND BY THE WAY, IT’S NOT JUST
DEMOCRATS YOU SHOULD BLAME FOR
THE CORROSION OF OUR PUBLIC
LIFE.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION INVESTIGATION OCCURRED
DURING THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF
THIS OF MENSURATION.
WHO RAN THE GOVERNMENT THEN?
REPUBLICANS CONTROLLED, THEY HAD
THE POWER TO EXPOSE THIS HOAX
AND SHUT IT DOWN BUT THEY DID
NOT.
WE CAN ONLY SPECULATE AS TO WHY
THEY DID NOT, PERHAPS TOO
COWARDLY TO TELL THE TRUTH OR
MAYBE DEEP DOWN A LOT OF THEM
AGREED WITH THE AIMS OF ALL OF
THIS.
EITHER WAY, IT WILL BE VERY
INTERESTING AND WE WILL SIT BACK
AND ENJOY IT AS LINDSEY GRAHAM
AT MITCH McCONNELL AND RICHARD
BURR IN SO MANY OF THE OTHER
USELESS REPUBLICANS, TOTAL PHONI
WHO TOLD YOU THEY ARE
REPRESENTING YOU BUT DON’T,
EXPLAIN WHY THEY DIDN’T DO